حان وقت ازاله الاتربه والسحور التي دفع
بها بركان سيميرو الى هذه السفوح رغم ان
البركان لم يخمد بعد في نظر الجيولوجيين
ولن يعود السكان للعيش في هذه المناطق في
المستقبل المنظور لخطورتها محمد زين الدين
من سكان كجر كونيك احدى القرى المنكوبه
دمر بيته هو الاخر لكن ذلك لم يمنعه من
الاستجابه لطلب الحكومه بالمشاركه في
مراقبه اعمال فتح هذا الطريق
اثار تضرري هذا الطريق واسع وكثيرون
يعتمدون على المرور به لنقل محصورهم من
الفواكه الى جزيره بالي ولو سلكوا طريقا
اخر لكان بعيدا للغايه لهذا نصلحه فهذا
الطريق اكثر لسكان المنطق يعود محمد حسن
الى حيه الذي دمر بالكامل مستذكرا ما وقع
عندما فر مع اهله حين بدا نشاط البركان
قبل ساعات من وقوع الفاوره الاكبر للحمم
حيث دفعت كميات هائله من الحجاره والادربه
لتغمر مساحات شاسعه وبسرعه خاطفه وهو معمق
معاناه الفلاحين
لا يعني مش عارف حريق
الفلاحين في ظل هذه الاحوال ان محصول ان
زراعيه غير مستقر ننتظر الحصاد عاده كل
خمسه اشهر لكننا خسرنا لثلاثه مواسم
متتاليه فقد ثار البركان العام الماضي
وهذا العام قبل ايام من حصاد محصولنا من
الارز والخضراوات
حاملين همه في فقدان اراضيهم الزراعيه
وليس منازلهم فحسن ومن اولئك ماتش هادي
فهو يحمل بمساعده جيرانه ما بقي من اخشاب
منزله للاستفاده منها كما فقد مزرعته التي
كان يقتات منها
لم يعد بالامكان السكن في هذه المنازل لان
بركان سميرو مازال ينفتح هما ما هو ودخانه
لهذا سننتقل الى المساكن المؤقته وانا
احمل هذه الاخشاب لاوسعه منزل المؤقت
الى هذه الودياني تدفق الحطام البركاني
الساخن من فوهه جبل سيميرو فغطت اتربته
وصخوره منازل باكملها وانحت فصولا من حياه
الناس فيها اما الناجون فلا يملكون الا
السعيه نحو بدايات جديده وكانت الحكومه
ونحو 50 منظمه انسانيه وشركه قد شيدت
مجمعا من المنازل المؤقته اثر ثوران
البركان العام الماضي ليضاف الى السفينه
هنا المتضررون من كارثه الايام الماضيه
كثيرون تسلموا مساكنهم واخرون ينتظرون
دورهم في الانتقالي الى هذا الحي
[موسيقى]
الجزيره اقليم جاوا الشرقيه